printemps été 1976 la france ufof depuis
des semaines de menaçantes la sécheresse
est en effet devenue une calamité
sécheresse continue à faire des ravages
dans toute l'europe la sécheresse donc
aujourd'hui fait figure de fléau
national à l'époque le pays connaît un
épisode de sécheresse intense le
thermomètre affiche régulièrement plus
de 35 degrés en juin et 5 i hate les
agriculteurs c'est une situation qui
s'annonce assez difficile et inquiétante
compte tenu du fait que nous avons eu la
dernière au niveau surtout des maïs et
avec deux peuples aux métriques nous
avons depuis le début de l'année on est
très inquiet au niveau des céréales en
plus des agriculteurs les éleveurs aussi
son impact et s'il n'y a pas d'eau il
n'y a pas de culture donc pas de
nourriture pour les bovins résultat les
bêtes sont envoyés à l'abattoir les
abattoirs tournent jour et demi
à battre des bovins produits tissés en
particulier des vaches laitières qui
sont
qui aurait dû être gardés dans le
cheptel qui sont rabattus maintenant
parce qu'il ya plus de fourrage
personne n'était pas reniée par la
chaleur des pompiers ravitailler les
villages en eau des militaires sont
déployés dans les campagnes des poissons
meurent à cause du réchauffement des
rivières dans certains villages on en
vient même à prier pour que la pluie
reviennent
j'estime que les gens qui ont la foi et
doivent continuer quand notre foi a
confié au seigneur leur souci est
actuellement cette sécheresse qui veut
devenir une catastrophe nationale les
villes aussi sont touchés à la ratp c'en
est trop les salariés se mettent en
grève à cause de la canicule
notez qu'à l'époque les bus ne sont pas
climatisées j'aimerais que ce pv de
serre avec les bars bride de plus on est
presque à six films hauteur et on se
retrouve dans le nez de la famille comme
actuellement la autour de quelques
manques on se retrouve avec des 55 60
degrés de chaleur
à conduire l'autobus et vous savez ces
trucs
pour faire face à la chaleur certaines
entreprises prennent des mesures pour
leurs salariés
dans cette blanchisserie de l'eau est
distribuée les horaires de travail
aménagés et puis regardez bien cette
verrière en dessous environ 200 ouvriers
y travaillent
en dessus des jets d'eau répandent une
pluie artificielle et cela en permanence
cet épisode de sécheresse ne
s'améliorent qu'à partir du mois
d'octobre quand la plus revient
aujourd'hui encore le printemps 1976 a
été le plus sec jamais enregistré depuis
le début du 20e siècle
[Musique]